كيف في سباق مع الزمن يعمل الفنيون ليل
نهارا لاصلاح ما يمكن اصلاحه نصف سكان
العاصمه الاوكرانيه بلا كهرباء
في شركه
للطاقه عن العمل ليلا ونهارا بفضلكم
يمكننا ان نعلن اليوم ان تدفئه عادات الى
97% من المنازل
الاوكرانيه بحلول
العسكريه الروسيه التي تواصل استهداف
البنيه التحتيه في البلاد لتترك ملايين
الاوكرانيين دون غاز او كهرباء او دون
كليهما
يا باشا
الجميع
هواتفكم وفكروا بالاتصال باحبتكم للتحضير
لما يمكن فعله في حال انقطاع الاتصالات
التقطت وكاله ناسا هذه الصوره مطلع شهر
شباط فبراير الماضي من السماء اوكرانيا
ومن نفس المكان التقطت هذه قبل ايام
الظلمه التغلب على البلاد التي تحذر الامم
المتحده من حدوث عمليات نزوح واسعه داخلها
او هجره جماعيه الى الخارج